الى العراق هناك اثار احد المعلمين الجدل
بعد تسريب مقطع له وهو يهين طالبه اثناء
درس في احد المعاهد الخاصه المقطع تبين
انه يعود مشاهدينا لمعلم كيمياء شهير في
بغداد يتابع مئات الالاف عبر التواصل
الاجتماعي ومنصاتها ومعروف بسلاسه شرحه
وعلاقه المقربه من تلاميذه لكن المقطع
المنتشر تسبب في غضب كبير تجاه هذا المعلم
وراى كثيرون ضروره معاقبته وحتى وقفه عن
التدريس وزاره التربيه العراقيه اصدرت
بيانا تقول فيه انها شكلت لجنه عاجله
للتحقيق حول مقطع الفيديو هذا
استدعاء
الساده كيف اذا حكينا عن الفيديو نفسه هل
هذا سلوك تربوي صحيح استاذ بيتكلم حتى وان
لم يعني لم يستعمل العنف الجسدي بالضرب او
كذا ولكن بالالفاظ هل هذا شيء مقبول
تربويا انه يحكي مع الطالبه بهذا الاسلوب
طبعا هذا
طبعا هذا السلوك غير مقبول اسلوب غير
تربوي لكن للاسف
العنف هو
ثقافه متجذره في المجتمع العراقي وفي
المجتمعات الابويه الذكوريه
الكثير يتغنى بهذا الاسلوب ويعتقد بان هذا
الاسلوب قد صنع نساء وصنع رجالا فربما
ينطلق البعض من هذا المفهوم للتعامل مع
طلابه استاذه شيماء يعني اليوم خليني انا
اخذ ايضا اقف على الاقل لا نستطيع ان نحكم
على مشهد هذا الفيديو لانه ما ندري الطالب
هي طالبه ماذا عملت وبالتالي ما الرساله
اذا كان معه حق من رساله الذي نوجهها
للطلاب
للطالب ان يكون هو مقوم لسلوك الطالب
المعلم يوفيه التبجيله هل هل نريد اليوم
من المعلم ان يكون هو ممنون للطالب انه
جاي يتعلم
كيف كيف نقف للمعلم وهو لا يحترم وهو لا
يعرف كيف ينتقي الفاظه بدقه اذا كان
الطالب غلطان يا استاذه شيماء حتى لو كان
الطالب حتى لو كان الطالب مسيء هذا
الاسلوب ليس صحيحا وين دور الاهل في هذه
في مشاكل من هذا النوع يعني زمان كانوا
الاهلي يشجعوا المعلم على تربيه الولد ولو
اضطر انه يضربوا ما في مشكله
ولكن الان النظره مختلفه الان انا مش راح
ارسل لا ارسل ابنائي للمدرسه حتى ينهانوا
نعم كانت في تلك الفتره هذه هي الثقافه
السائده الثقافه الذكوريه الابويه نحن
كلنا تعرضنا للتعنيف قد تكون قد نفعت هذه
في وقت من الاوقات لاننا لم نكن نعرف ما
هي حقوقنا لكن هذه الاجيال تعرف ما هي
حقوقها بحكم الانفتاح بحكم الاطلاع فهذا
الاسلوب لم يعد نافع في الوقت الحاضر
واذا تريد
اخر وحده